congresswoman susie lee thank you so
much for joining us
and my first question um is about some
endorsements maybe
unexpected like the review journal uh
chamber of commerce usually going
republican but they endorsed you what do
you want to say about that
well listen i am proud to have those
endorsements and i think it's a
reflection of the work that i've done in
congress
since i've been there for two years of
really trying to work
uh with both parties across the aisle in
a bipartisan manner
to get things done that are so important
to nevada families and
i think there's a recognition that i'm
putting politics aside and trying to get
progress and solve problems
as you know i joined the problem solvers
caucus which is a caucus of 25 democrats
and 25 republicans when i first came to
congress
and really that was my commitment to the
constituents of congressional district 3
that
they actually want to see a member of
congress who's going to
try to outreach and build relationships
uh with members of both parties because
as we know this is such
a polarized time in this country and
what i hear from my constituents is they
just want to see that we're actually
getting together having those tough
conversations because everything isn't
black and white
and a lot of these issues do require a
lot of back and forth and compromise
in policy discussions and so you need to
have someone
who's committed to doing that and i
think that that was both of those
endorsements
are recognition that that's the type of
leadership i bring to this sea
you mentioned the problem solvers caucus
what would you say is your biggest
bipartisan
achievement well listen i mean we've
passed uh
i think the biggest thing that the
problem solvers caucus has done was our
break the gridlock package
which really was to address some of the
rules that have prevented
uh things from coming to the floor of
the house so for instance we
got a rule passed that if you get us
co-sponsorship of 290 members of
congress
it has to be bipartisan at that point
that it has to come to the floor of the
house for a vote
and you know you think about it there
have been many
pieces of legislation that have had uh
wide support across this country
that have been prevented from even
getting their time
in congress by the leadership and so
that's it that's a big accomplishment of
this and then
uh probably the biggest thing is as you
know
the democrats in the house we passed the
heroes act
uh over five months ago it had been
sitting on mitch mcconnell's desk
there was really no movement about it it
was a stalemate
about a month ago we came together the
problem solvers caucus really
it was just all of us rank and file
members and said how can we get these
negotiations moving again because
as you know especially here in southern
nevada we have so many families
that are struggling that are worried
about paying rent putting food on their
table
and so we got together and put together
our own package of guidelines
and it was instrumental in restarting
the negotiations that are happening
right now so
um even the president even tweeted out a
couple days ago
that it's the problem solvers uh package
that he's looking
at as a compromise so i think it's you
know really taking
um us having that tough conversation us
looking at all the different issues and
trying to find out
what is it that we can get pat like what
is it we can get done
because ultimately we have to get
a third stimulus package passed and it
cannot wait until after the election and
so we've been instrumental
in forcing and pushing and cajoling
our leadership to get this package
passed
and since it is stalled should it be
passed piece by piece then
uh listen i you know i'm a proponent of
looking at comprehensive because who
you what are we how are we gonna make
those trade-offs that
you know we obviously we want the
aviation industry
uh to succeed and not go under but also
here in nevada we have so many small
business owners
restaurant owners our live entertainment
you know and so to me i think it's all a
comprehensive package we have to look at
you know extending unemployment benefits
look at
testing and tracing and so i'd like to
see it come together as a comprehensive
package
if it just can't come together as a
comprehensive package though
could you maybe list i know you said
everything is important but could you
maybe list
top three priorities in your opinion
uh you know the biggest priority for me
is
obviously state and local funding um you
know
we have seen in nevada about a quarter
of our state budget has a hole in it
because of this
uh pandemic and basically we have
already given state and local funding
but a lot of it was
dedicated towards expenses that were
related to covid19 and so
uh looking at um assistance to states
that will help them when they've seen a
reduction of
revenue as we're seeing here in southern
nevada
and i believe listen we're not going to
get past the economic fallout
of this virus until we get past the
public health crisis
so i believe that this 75 billion
dollars or additional funding
not just funding for a testing and
tracing strategy
but also a strategy and making sure it's
one that we can move
to allow our schools to open allow
our bigger convention spaces to open etc
if we had
rapid testing if we were able to
concentrate that testing
in in a way that and i know that there's
several businesses here who are taking
it upon themselves
but just think about how incredibly
powerful
that would be if the federal government
could take a leadership
in that and um and then you know the
extension of the ppp
program that's been incredibly important
to our state we've had over
close to 45 000 businesses uh use those
resources over a half a million jobs
um you know i mean the list goes on
unemployment
extended unemployment benefits another
uh stimulus check i just feel that we
had done such incredible bipartisan work
with the family's first act
and then the cares bill and now it's
really when
you know we are seeing people they that
are on the precipice
and we need to get that additional aid
there
you know housing and rental assistance
as well is so important too
um you have a background in education
what is the solution in the middle of a
pandemic
should students be back in the classroom
well first of all i think that's our
ultimate goal and we know
that distance learning uh is not
the is not the preferred outcome here we
want to get students back in the
classroom
safely um you know i think again
to me this all comes back with what are
we doing to stop the community spread
what are we doing to make sure that
we're getting the incidence of
covet 19 down in our community
protecting you know
again we know that students or
young kids can be carriers can become
they might not get as sick but then
they go home to families where family
members might have a comorbidity
or another pre-existing conditions or
teachers may have it
and so to me it's really measuring what
we're doing to stop the
community spread uh but also how we can
keep people safe
and ultimately it comes to funding when
you think about it
if we could you know even if we did a
hybrid model
where kids went for two days on two days
out that's increased
transportation it's increased staffing
all of that takes additional funding
additional ppe even if you were to do
additional testing which i think is so
important you know where we have seen
schools that have opened and have been
relatively successful they've been able
to identify
a spread before it got out of hand and
isolated and that's going to be really
important but again
all of that requires funding and that's
why the state and local funding is so
incredibly important
as a part of the heroes 2.0 act anything
um you'd like to add
about that additional challenge for
parents of students with special needs
with
the distance learning yeah i
listen i mean we have seen our most
vulnerable students
have been falling further and further
behind whether it is
students who are living in poverty who
didn't have access to either internet or
the devices
but also our special needs because they
require
that additional touch point they require
the additional resources
and how are we delivering that you know
online
is important you know that's been an
important issue that i've been an
advocate for i was i introduced the bill
protect our students act which is
basically
uh i'm sorry keep our pact act which is
basically to fully fund
idea and title one traditionally the
federal government has never given
those exact resources to our state it
would mean about 400 million dollars a
year
uh for our state funding if we as a
federal government fully funded
uh those resources and so again to me a
lot of this comes down to making sure
we're continuing to fight
for the necessary resources we need
but also you know we all have to work
together
to stop the spread of this virus and we
know
that the economic fallout our fallout
for our
families who are you know having to
teach their students at home
we can beat this and literally we have
the we have the resources at our
fingertips it's called a mask
and if people would simply just wear
that
and social distance not be in large
groups but
to me it's so important especially for
our special ed students to get back into
the classroom
uh joe biden joe biden finally said he
is not a fan of court packing
what are your thoughts listen i
you know my thoughts are right now we
are
faced with the most major
crisis at least in my lifetime in this
country this pandemic
families are on the brink of collapse
businesses are on the brink of
bankruptcy
and this administration is choosing
to rush through supreme court hearings
at this point um looking at basically
being able to place a justice on the
court just in time
for the supreme court hearing on the
affordable care act
which would take away protections for
pre-existing conditions from millions of
americans
so i find it that right now
as i've said before i am a one issue
congresswoman at this point i think the
biggest issue facing congress right now
is making sure we get another package
past the finish line
onto the president's desk and signed
uh moving on to dan rojimer
um one of his attack ads
claims that you are nancy pelosi's
puppet what do you want to say about
that
uh dan rhodeimer is taking a book out of
the republican party playbook
and basically i think that my
endorsements speak for themselves the
review journal
uh the chamber of commerce i've been
ranked by the lugar center which ranks
members based on their bipartisanship as
one of the most bipartisan members of
congress
uh and so i think it's a false attack
but
it's basically one that is being played
all across this country uh
by my on you know by republicans who are
uh going after seats held by democrats
and
um you know but then you have to look at
what
rhode islanders uh what rhode
record is and basically he's running on
a record
of basically being pro-trump and he's
holding on to those coattails and so i
think it's an interesting attack
your campaign has really focused on his
history
he points out that he's never been
convicted of a crime
listen i think he has a well-documented
long history of violence and fraud and
i felt that it was important for the
voters of congressional district 3
to know that you know whether it was the
waffle house i mean
he was basically ordered to attend an
anger management class
in response to that attack multiple
phone calls not just from his house here
but also
a separate instance incidents down in
florida
of domestic violence and so i think
people
need to understand uh the type of
violence that
has been a pattern for dan rodeimer
voters have been inundated with the
mailers the commercials the attack
how concerned are you that this will be
a tight race or that he will win
listen this is a you know this seat was
drawn to be a traditionally
swing district it will be you know it
has always been a tight race in the seat
what i'm concerned about is i believe
that people want to have a congress
member
who has demonstrated not just by what
they've done
here in our community but has
demonstrated i have the experience of
showing that i've been able to roll up
my sleeves and work with people of the
other party
i think that the divisiveness and the
dysfunction in this country is so
distressing
especially right now where people are on
the brink
uh with respect to the economy wanting
people to work together
uh you know this dan rhodeimer his
slogan is i'm gonna take a chair to the
back of washington
he says that in one breath and then
turns around in the next and says but
i'm going to work together
i don't know about you but traditionally
when i try to work with people i
actually
speak to them with respect instead of
threatening them
and so you know i believe that voters
are going to look at my 25-year track
record in our community
um you know from day one when i moved
here
i have gotten after the issues that are
facing us whether it is
homelessness uh you know i started the
city's first comprehensive homeless
center when the school district cut
after school programs i started the
inner city games which is now the after
school all-stars
and then when we had our dropout problem
i rolled up my sleeves took over the
helm of communities and schools
which today is now the state's largest
and most effective
dropout prevention program so i believe
that
boaters are going to look at that track
record they're going to look at my track
record in in
dc and they're going to understand that
i'm the type of leadership
that we need more of in washington i
juxtapose that to dan rhodeimer who is
basically clinging to the
the coattails of this president i
haven't really heard
a plan of what he has for the future
uh basically you know it's one thing to
say you don't like something but it's
another thing to get to work
and try to fix it and i've demonstrated
i have a track record of being able to
do that
donald trump did win cd3 by one point
in 2016. what about that concern and
have
voters noticed enough of a change
um to vote democrat
listen um you know donald trump won it
by a point i
i was able to carry this district by
nine points uh
in 2018. um to me
this race is not about donald trump this
race to me
is about the people of southern nevada
i we are ground zero for the economic
devastation
of this pandemic we have a large and
vibrant
community we have a large community of
retirees who are worried about medicare
and social security we have you know
parents who are sending their you know
or teaching their children
online at home and i believe that it
will be a referendum
of not only who is going to help us
rebuild and you know my background
in our community of taking on the
toughest problems
i believe that i'm a member of the
education and labor committee
we have a we have a long path to
get out of this economic crisis but a
lot of it
will obviously go through workforce
development
making sure that we're bringing funds
into our community
to support retraining or training our
workforce
and i've already have a track record of
doing that nevada state college just
announced a two million dollar grant
that i would
help them secure uh to help with their
education
training programs uh especially
important because it's a hispanic
serving institution
um and then i also was able to get a
million dollars for
area health education centers again
another
key workforce development program of
making sure we're training people
for jobs of tomorrow and so um
to me i believe that this race is about
someone who's willing to get out there
figure out how we're getting resources
into our state to help us rebuild
uh instead of someone who's going to
repeat
the divisive and violent rhetoric that
we have heard for the past four years
i think people are really tired of
the fear of the violence that we've seen
and they want to see someone who's
actually going to work together and
that's the key difference
in this race between myself and dan
rhodeimer
there were several debates on the table
but you did not
agree to one for now
why not listen uh dan rhodeimer had
agreed to a pbs debate
um i agreed to it as well and then he
backed out
basically um and so you know it's on to
him i agreed to a debate he had agreed
to
we offered a debate though huh
we also and i had yes and i had said
because
of uh basically his health practices
of having rallies and events with no
mass
that i was willing to do one debate i
accepted the one debate that he had
accepted and then he turned it down
um we've asked you about this before i'm
going to ask you
again for viewers who may not have seen
those
previous interviews um there was
controversy about your role with ppp
loans and your husbands or your family's
business what do you want to say about
that
what happened uh well listen i i think
everyone remembers back in march when we
passed the
cares act the ppp program um
one of the key things that was really an
administration
issue uh that had prevented gaming
companies companies that derived some of
their revenues from gaming
they were prevented from accessing the
key
small business program that was part of
the cares act
simply because they had gaming revenues
i along with
our entire bipartisan delegation not
just here in nevada that across the
country
many states who have a large gaming
presence we
lobbied to make sure that gaming was
included
in in the ppp program now i want to say
prior to that fix nevada ranked almost
near the bottom
in terms of the percentage of small
businesses
that benefited from the ppp program
after
now we have seen close to 45 000
businesses
responsible for half a million jobs have
access to those critical funds
i was doing my job by advocating to make
sure
that gaming was included in this program
along with
our entire delegation my husband's
company
i applied for it i had no decision in
their and them applying i had no deci i
had no role in sba's decision of
approving the loan
and i certainly won't have any rule in
the repayment of the loan
uh you know they claim that those funds
went to support
about 700 jobs uh that's exactly what
the program was intended to do to
support
employment and it was so important for
our state
uh and it was egregious that gaming was
cut
out of that program and i just did my
job by advocating for that
how concerned are you though that voters
may have heard about this or hear about
this and
think well maybe there is a conflict of
interest and
maybe she's just another politician
who's out for themselves how concerned
are you about that and what would you
say to them
i you know again i'd say that this was
an emission of the key industry in our
state
and at a time when to protect the lives
of
our fellow nevadans of americans we
asked major businesses to completely
shut down and gaming was one of them
and it was my duty to make that fight to
make sure that
our main industry our main economy
driver
was covered by this key program but
ultimately i think people need to look
at my track record
uh 25 years in this community you know i
say look at
what they have done and what the which
will
give you a good idea of what they're
about and what they're gonna do
and you know from the minute i got here
i got to work
on key issues facing our most vulnerable
residents whether it was our homeless
community
our school children our kids who are at
risk of dropping out and so you know
i've demonstrated
in my career that i've been able to get
results
and roll up my sleeves and focus on the
issues that affect nevadans
and i think that's what people are going
to be thinking about
especially now as we're looking for who
are we going to have on our side
that's going to look past the political
uh rhetoric and dig in
and get to what we actually need to do
to rebuild our economy
and i think the choice is clear